how does your creative path as an
actress and producer differ from your
path as a physician or how are they
similar many interesting question
medicine I don't consider it as a
creative path in my mind it is something
that has already been generated over
years of research and experience and put
into books and you learn that in medical
school and you learn how to treat
certain diseases and conditions and how
to approach patients so there is a
protocol for everything in medicine and
as you go through life as a physician
you generate your own way of how it is
the most effective way to deal with your
own patients and your own healing
process for them but I don't consider
that creative by any means because you
you are using your mind you're using
your memory of intelligence of years of
experience and study to understand what
is happening in that person's mind or
body and you are trying to heal that so
I mean there may be other opinions other
doctors may find this a creative process
and that is perfectly fine but to me
it's not creative it's just more of an
analytical sort of process and it's a
more heart to heart connection process
when you're when you're dealing with a
human being in front of you and trying
to heal their pain it's more of
analyzing the problem putting your own
emotion as a human being as an as a
person who has knowledge in that field
across and trying to heal them so if if
you're connecting the creativity
portions I don't think that's similar at
all but films to me is a completely
creative medium you know there is a the
it's an amalgamation of personalities of
ideas of egos of conflicts of crazy
visions of dreams of you know bringing
humanity to the limit of whatever we can
explore and putting it on screen so to
me though that's how it appears so the
two are very separate but you're somehow
able to live a life where you devote
time to both of them and they're both
very important to you for a long time
yes in the in the last couple of years
my my focus is shifting to producing
films with great messages as you know
both are very time consuming professions
for a long time I did manage to do both
but as you grow to a certain level you
realize okay the balance of shifting so
I have worked as a physician for hours
and hours and hours at a time without
breaks and emergency rooms you know and
and during those times there was nothing
else in my mind but that it was about
patient care it was about healing I
never ever in my mind at that moment I
never was anything else but a physician
but once I finished that whole stint of
shifts or that whole set of work in a
particular little town I was a small
town traveling emergency physician that
was how I managed both professions I
once I finished that set of work I would
go away to my filming arena and then let
all of that out that was my that closed
off my work as a physician and it
entered into the realm of creativity do
you remember when that shift happened do
you remember was there a certain
incident something where you said that
you felt more drawn toward one over the
other no I have always ever since I can
remember as a little child been drawn to
larger-than-life pneus I don't know
whether it was more of an attention
grabbing technique in the beginning you
know when as a child I was always I
wanted to be the center of attention I
wanted to speak out about things I
wanted to to perform my classical dance
and I never had any trouble with that
and but coming from a background a very
very academic traditional background of
south indian family that i came from
there was nobody in the family who were
from the performing arts in any of the
several generations they were all
scholastic they were all Sanskrit
scholars they were temple priests and in
in documented history my grandfather BB
pundit was an Ayurvedic physician and he
set the tone for you know a larger than
life he had 11 children and my father
being one of them my youngest one and so
I grew up in this whole kind of academic
cultural family where tradition reigned
supreme and it was beautiful but it was
also very structured and I kind of had
this pad set out for me from the very
beginning because my grandfather was an
Ayurvedic physician my father is a ISM
is an allopathic physician he's
practicing cardiologist actually
internal medicine now he did cardiology
but he's practicing internal medicine so
it was kind of like almost you know that
legacy and and I was always told oh
she's going to grow up to be a physician
and it was it was just that you know it
was almost a given and I was certainly
not opposed to it because I really
adored and respected my dad and my
granddad so I was like yeah sure why not
you know II you don't know when you're
very young what exactly your life is
going to turn out to be obviously so so
yeah and that's that's how it happened I
was good in my academic studies but at
the same time there was this there was
this constant side it never ever
collided it was always it happened
beautifully side by side I either I'm
lucky or I I was always good with my
academic work but at the same time I was
always in drama in dramatics in school I
was learning Bharata Natyam dancing
which is a disciplined art form from the
age of seven onwards learning carnatic
classical music waking up early in the
morning mom used to wake me up for
practice at
6am so the teacher used to come home and
you sit and learn the the art for an
hour and then go to school so it's a it
was a very structured and cultural and
disciplined upbringing but there was
also freedom my parents had that insight
i think they always they would guide me
and structure me a certain way but then
when they saw that I had a little bit of
a different tilt they never curbed it
but they always said you have to be good
in your academics you have to have a
solid background to always fall back on
you always have to be independent do not
depend on anybody for your financial
freedom ever and you know for me that
was it was ingrained and I think that's
why I kind of it went bilateral all the
time and it was I think only post my
medical school and then when I started
my residency and when I came in to that
point of my own financial independence
happening that's when the branch out
started I was like okay I can do both I
can and I can do both and I don't have
to depend on anybody for both you know
and luckily for me i had this medical
background where i could finance my own
journey towards where I wanted to go and
yes I do have a very long way to go in
either field but the fact is I was able
to confidently make strides into both
the fields and that's what I'm very
thankful to my family for you know for
giving me that background because many
times as you know the this field the
field of films and fashion and and media
is is quite toys a roller coaster in
terms of being of getting jobs in in
terms of the the ups and downs that can
happen you know suddenly you're one on a
high one day the next day you're not in
that film anymore or whatever and that
can throw people off right and so much
and is it can it can be very
traumatizing so luckily I had that
background so I never gave up on that
until very recently you know right very
recently is when that that full shift is
happening where I'm hoping to keep
acting and producing and giving more
important breaks
people like me who you know are trying
to come in and trying to have avenues
and create films you know that's what
I'm hoping to do but let's see how far
it goes life every day's an adventure
life is unpredictable but you know you
go forward
you